comme ça sent bon louise est de chercher
plénière recel
pour m une guérite r vous vous sentez
comment ça c'est compliqué je sais qui
vous êtes
évitez vous faire remarquer
je vais prendre combien votre avis je
sais pas c'est pas mon métier
moi ce qui m'importe c'est que ça se
passe bien ici ok pour vous aider ou j
ça c'est pas moi qui suis enfermé
d'après vous qu'est ce qui fait qu'on
tombe amoureux de quelqu'un mais croyez
au dessin paraît qu'on récolte ce que
l'on sème
alors je voudrais que tout ce qui
m'arrive
alors c'est quoi le problème
enfin je prends moi tu sais je me suis
jamais senti aussi bien fou
m
je n'attendrai pas éternellement
tu te rappelles
je fais une connerie je suis désolé
turquie
bagis moi c'est pour monter dans marine
tout vient du fait des communes
vous faites tomber raconte tout ce que
je sais
je t'avais dit qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai tout lâché
des fois j'ai envie de tout ça